it has been a grueling 19 months since
an american horror story episode has
aired it honestly feels like an eternity
in murder house you are going to
die in there but we finally have
something to tide us over
until ahs double feature arrives later
next month
and tide is a good word since double
feature will contain
two types of stories one from the sea
and one from the sand
but today we're looking at the spin-off
show american horror stories which as
far as i know
are self-contained stories that are
loosely linked through the ahs universe
unlike a typical season of ahs which
spans 10 or so episodes there will be
new stories every week with the
exception of week 1 and 2
which is a two-parter and let me tell
you there are so many easter eggs and
fun little details in these first two
episodes
if you've been a fan of the show since
the beginning some of these will easily
pop
out while others are a bit more hidden
but that's where i got you covered if
you're new to the channel one of the
first shows i
ever covered was ahs apocalypse i'll
leave some links to the ahs playlist i
have below
and i'm really hoping horror stories
isn't just fanservice and that we get
some unique
and fun additions like if this show
could be black mirror but with horror
you've got me sold so in this video
we'll be looking at episodes 1 and 2 of
american horror stories
breaking it down and pointing out all
the references to the ahs
universe so put on your rubber suit make
sure to hug this guy and last but not
least
don't forget to like and subscribe
because here we
go welcome back to murder house yes if
you're familiar with season one or even
apocalypse you know
about this place built in 1922 by
surgeon to the stars charles montgomery
it was the main focus of season one
and part of season eight where michael
the antichrist was born
long story short if you die on the
premises you return as a ghost
scarlett here is our protagonist for the
first two episodes moving in with her
two dads who want to turn the place into
a haunted bed and breakfast
this isn't the first time we've seen a
gay couple move into murder house in
season 1 we had
chad and patrick chad ends up being one
of several characters who don
the rubber suit to kill along with tate
langdon ben
harmon and michael langdon scarlett will
end up wearing the suit as
well as being the first rubber woman
which is the name of this episode
outside the home we'll see these hanging
bones just like in the first episode of
season one and as scarlett unpacks in
her new home we'll see this
butterfly frame in fact butterflies can
be found all
over her room just like a caterpillar
turns into a butterfly so too does
scarlett become her true self by the end
of episode 2.
you'll also see her wearing necklaces
that evoke her own emotional prison like
this one here with handcuffs
and this one a chain to make things
creepier this red ball rolls into the
room
a reference to beauregard langdon's ball
he used to play with while
chained in the attic this is supposed to
lead her to the rubber suit and of
course as soon as you find a creepy s
m suit you just have to try it on at
high school where scarlet is an outcast
the teacher talks about a part of the
brain called the amygdala the part that
starts firing off signals when you're
scared some people can turn this part of
their brain off but in the process
lose their emotions as we'll find out
later it's heavily implied scarlett's
amygdala doesn't function properly she
has no fear in
kills without empathy her best friend
shanti echoes this statement in episode
2 by adding that scarlet shares the same
traits as a psychopath scarlett starts a
fling with popular girl maya played by
paris jackson
michael jackson's daughter this crush
manifests at home when scarlett dreams
of making out with her and you may even
hear this
whistle tune
this is the same tune tate langdon
whistled in season one so it's a nice
call back and of course
rubber man himself is watching over her
now some people have said this is tate
langdon watching in the background with
his green sweater but i just don't buy
it
let me know what you think in the
comments below while scarlett heads off
to school her parents sit her down to
talk about her recent internet searches
which include
violent bdsm and are they not even gonna
mention this weird ass mural they
uncover in the background in a future
scene we can get a better
shot of it which looks like someone
performing an exorcist on a woman
which may be a slight nod to scarlett
being possessed when she kills
scarlet decides it would be funny to
prank her parents by holding a knife and
dressing up in the rubber suit but when
her dad tries to take it off her he's
accidentally cut
that leads into the next day where they
have a family therapy session which
outlines scarlett's past
when she was three she was kidnapped by
a crazed woman who had lost her own
child
she was gone for 10 days but has no
recollection of these events
we never really find out how this
affects the story and it's never brought
up again
it may have just been to hammer home the
fact she doesn't get scared and her
parents are overprotective
meanwhile the therapist follows the red
ball and we can catch a glimpse
of the two redhead boys who were killed
in murder house in season one
she heads into the basement where she is
killed by the rubber man now becoming a
permanent part of the house it's kind of
weird doane comes looking for her for
the entire two episodes so scarlett ends
up sneaking out of the house to attend a
slumber party with maya and her friends
but when she's left alone with her crush
she opens up about being turned on by
pain and
torture this however is all a cruel joke
put on by maya and her friends who have
secretly live streamed the whole
thing essentially embarrassing scarlet
in front of her entire school who now
thinks she's a pervert scarlett decides
to get back at them
warning that she'll kill herself and
blame it on them if they don't come over
and outside the house one of the girl
remarks that she once went on a [ __ ]
tour of la where they talked about
murder house which is a throwback to
when vivian harmon found a horror tour
bus outside her home
scarlett as the rubber woman kills maya
and her friends as the song tonight you
belong to me plays
another song that was used in season one
you may have even noticed the infantata
creature who was a being crafted
together by
charles montgomery using pieces of his
dead child
near the end of the first episode were
also greeted by the now dead therapist
who says she's fighting for office hours
because another therapist is in the
house
this of course is a reference to ben
harmon the therapist patriarch of season
one
you might also be asking yourself how
come we don't see any of these other
famous murder house ghosts this is
likely due to both covet and
budget restrictions in episode two we
get our first glimpse of ruby mcdaniel
who becomes scarlett's love interest
in her first scene we see her killing
the ghost of nurse gladys who has made
appearances in both season 1
and apocalypse her childhood was marked
by a horribly abusive man named tony
her real parents sold her to him so she
decided to kill herself in murder house
in an attempt to make the news but when
the realtor found her she ended up
burying the body to avoid the price of
the house going down
now this could be a nod to marcy the
realtor from season 1 who often withheld
information from her clients in an
attempt to make a sale
scarlett here has settled into tate
langdon's former room
fitting since both characters turn mad
detectives arrive
looking for the murdered girls but again
no one seems to be looking for the
therapist
speaking of her michael tells her that
he's being haunted by a pig man
this is a throwback to episode 6 of
season 1 entitled piggy piggy where one
of ben harmon's patience is haunted by a
chicago butcher who murders wearing a
pig's head with renovations on the house
taking longer than expected and troy
having to dig into scarlet's college
fund to pay for it they enlist the help
of
adam the contractor a contractor who
ends up having an affair with troy it's
all playing out too similar to murder
house where ben had an affair but things
really take a turn when adam's co-worker
martin stumbles upon the bodies of the
missing girls
and what does adam do well he kills
martin of course
he's so in debt that he blackmails troy
and michael into being partners not only
in the haunted bnb idea
but also in their marriage michael ends
up kicking him out where he's promptly
killed by the rubber man and we soon
find out that both troy and michael have
already been killed they've been killed
by ruby they just don't remember because
apparently it was a traumatic experience
and they blocked it out of their minds
okay i guess we'll go with it this is
also ruby's attempt to keep scarlett her
lover
at murder house without actually killing
her scarlet ends up finding out her
parents are dead and i guess it's
because she has no empathy she gets over
it pretty quickly
going out later that night with ruby to
celebrate halloween
in season one we learn that the ghosts
of murder house have one night a year
where they can leave the house and
that's halloween so the murdered girls
seeking revenge construct a plan to kill
scarlett off of the property this way
when she dies she won't be able to come
back and she'll be separated from ruby
forever it's like a revenge version of
killing two birds with one stone
ruby and scarlet decide to spend their
night out on the town at a local haunted
house where we can see a freak show in
the background freak show of course was
the theme of season 4.
inside the haunted house we'll see one
of the haunters who looks a lot like
lady gaga's character skathach from
season six
i never know how to pronounce that but
date night doesn't go as expected when
scarlett is chased down by
maya and the girls she'll survive but
later when she meets the other girls
outside the house and apologizes to them
they just kind of drop it it felt very
anticlimactic
scarlett tells ruby she can't stay in
the house she loves ruby but wants to
explore the world
ruby is okay with this and 10 months
later we see scarlet as track down
ruby's abuser
and takes him out with a hammer while
wearing the rubber suit
and scarlett ends up showing up to
halloween every year to visit ruby and
her
parents not sure why it's only once a
year she can visit them anytime but
whatever and last little easter egg is
the normal people scare me shirt ruby
wears which tate langdon also wore in
season 1.
now if you want my opinion of the first
two episodes i thought it was just
very average i really wanted them to do
something different but
everything in the episode it felt like
i've seen before but i want to know what
you guys thought of the first two
episodes let me know in the comments
below thanks for watching everyone
remember to like and subscribe and for
more bad takes you can always follow me
on twitter and instagram at thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
you